the hospitality is the lifeblood of our  valley hotel workers they keep our  resorts going and hopefully keep  customers coming back and today we share  the love today is national hotel  employee day there are nearly 2 million  hotel workers all across the country  here in southern nevada we have more  than 220 000 employees in the leisure  and hospitality injury thanks for  keeping our sheets fresh  now one of those workers is heading into  retirement yesterday caesar's palace  rolled out the red carpet for  blackjack dealer benny figgins there you  see him there he's retiring after  working at caesars for more than 55  years  figgins is one of the few employees  who's been at the resort since it opened  back in 1966 he also met his wife there  way to go benny we're back